the Joe Rogan experience how much you
must be getting I mean this is like the
first time probably the lbgtq community
has gotten behind a strong man though I
mean this isn't even just a pro athlete
general really you know I think well
that's like that's the biggest reason
for my Instagram name is just like
showing LGBTQ like visibility in pro
sports because it doesn't exist right
you know like there's a few infighting
the UFC Amanda Nunez was the greatest
women of all time she's gay oh.what
which is great and that's a cool but men
mmm
different animal yeah you know I think
like there's this really big disconnect
where like people think like okay
lesbian women are allowed to be strong
they're allowed to be athletic they can
do all these really cool things gay men
have to be feminine they have to be put
in this box and they shouldn't be pro
athletes and that's one of the biggest
reasons why I'm so you know I called
myself like unapologetically open about
my sexuality because like it really is
you know the more you think about it
like if you even try to think of like an
openly gay man in any pro sport across
the world no there's no really
mainstream I think you forgot about
Brian Boitano oh coucher don't you
remember South Park will would Brian
Boitano do yeah Brian Boitano I mean
he's a goddamn trailblazer but yeah
other than figure skating who actively
competing in right or sport there really
isn't anything and I'm saying like you
know strongman is by no means like major
or mainstream yet but we're getting
there
people know about it for sure and I
think to see like an openly gay man you
know I say competing and arguably one of
the most like hyper masculine sports in
the world
yeah you know I think like when I think
of masculine sports I think like UFC and
lifting [ __ ] right yeah like right like
one you're beating another dude up the
other one it's a bunch of guys standing
around a weight being like oh I'm gonna
pick it up no I'll pick it up I'll pick
it up faster you know like it's like
Neanderthal almost yeah that's top of
the food chain manly [ __ ] exactly yeah
so I think it's like super important to
see like an openly gay man in
relationship rocking a rainbow Mohawk
and rainbow tights out on a competition
floor I think that makes people feel
more comfortable than if you just out
there sling and dick yeah you weren't in
a relationship you were openly gay and
just [ __ ] tourists like hey this guy
pick up the [ __ ] moon and he could
but [ __ ] you well that's danger I was
like one of my buddies he said he's like
you know I'm not afraid of you but what
does scare me is if you wanted to rape
me well don't definitely don't ready but
if you were gonna disrupt you could grab
me right here yeah that's uh but yeah
those are definitely I mean right after
fighting that is the most manly [ __ ]
picking [ __ ] up exactly you know so I
think that's why like that's why you
know I've been so open about my
relationship and what I'm doing in the
sport and just trying to be more visible
for the LGBTQ community in pro sports in
general you know cuz like I said before
like I get a [ __ ] ton of hate messages
on a daily basis and read them all the
time why do you even love it really um
and I know a lot of people don't but
like to me I use it as fuel like there's
no bigger [ __ ] you to that person than
me winning right you know like so that's
how I that's how I look at it like okay
dude talk [ __ ] about me all you want I'm
the American log press record holder
yeah I won in Australia I'm competing
against the top I'm one of the top 10
strongest men in the world competing at
this Arnall strongman Classic in March
so that's why I love it like I love
reading that but like it is a funny
thing you said that got in the audience
it's great right but the crowd goes
silent my favorite polish because that
was California people post our cheering
yeah well they lick Mainers but totally
sidetracked on that's a not sucking dick
and they you know I get it it's you
would think that you would have a lot of
sponsors that would jump in because of
this though I would think because you're
open and because this is such a manly
sport and it's such a non stereotypical
thing
yeah I would think that would be like
really positive for the lbgtq community
yeah I mean let's talk in a week girl
let's see what happens after your show
I'm hoping we can help you it's um you
know and that's my biggest thing like
while doing this whole thing is like
just trying to spread positivity and
love throughout the entire world you
know I mean I talk about the hate
messages that I get but like the ones
that mean a lot are like you know I got
a message a few months ago from a 16
year old kid who was on the verge of
committing suicide because he couldn't
come to terms with the sexuality right
and he said in his in his post like
finding my profile
let him be comfortable with himself you
know that's awesome crazy that's so good
it's like it's I never expected to be
that person just by saying I love this
dude but you know sometimes how you get
to be that person right yeah and
yourself exactly and I think that's
that's why this whole thing has kind of
blown up into what it is and why I'm you
know fortunate enough to now be working
on a documentary
what's the documentary so we literally
our we I just met the film crew this
week those guys out there yeah the ones
out there okay so I was approached by
Andy who she was on the set of world
Strongest Man and she was like once she
saw my husband and I kiss after one of
the events like light bulbs just went
off and she was like there's something
here so I was approached about doing a
documentary count about my life and the
belt being the only openly gay Pro star
man in the world
now are there closeted gays strong men
I'm sure there are and they just don't
talk to you probably you're dangerous
I know it's wild [ __ ] with a
mold I know my [ __ ] coming for my
title you want to keep in the closet
Moore's little cart start coming now
we're gonna have to actually have have a
contest for this what if it what if
strongmen becomes like the WNBA where
everyone's gay I'm just selfish I mean
that's a good argument that sponsors
won't show up though cuz [ __ ]
everybody knows that WNBA is gay as [ __ ]
true but it's bad basketball too yeah
it's not great that's not good yeah like
at least strong
women sports awesome but like I always
think of like the the Family Guy episode
where they're talking about the WNBA and
they're like oh and listen to the fan
that's one guy cheering on the fat and
stands yeah it's it's a tough sell it is
[Applause]